pas
oh
m
bonjour chers télénautes pour ce nouveau
numéro de diagonale tv sur canal web
avec notre ami et loire lange le jeune
grand maître bonsoir bertrand bonsoir à
vous amis internautes
alors cette semaine une émission chargée
puisque on a trois rubriques
nous avons une première rubrique avec
l'événement de la semaine le grand prix
du sénat canal web
après une analyse avec toi et loi pour
la grande partie du du grand prix du
sénat et enfin les l'actualité de la
semaine avec surtout on va pouvoir
annoncer le tournoi de sarajevo
alors on commence par la première
rubrique l'événement de la semaine
c'était le grand prix du sénat et loire
comment ça s'est passé
et bien donc nous allons lancer la
rubrique la première brique de ce
diagonale l'événement de la semaine
alors alors l'événement de la semaine
c'est bien entendu le grand prix d'échec
du sénat avec donc les fameux 4 joueurs
qui ont été qualifiés par par
l'organisation diagonale disons les
quatre les quatre joueurs ont été
sélectionnés avec évidemment la grande
star du tournoi c'était boris spassky
qui est notre notre champion du monde
note la demande en 1969 le grand le
grand boris
il y avait également le numéro 4 mondial
alexei shirov le numéro un français joël
lautier et en os charles le coup de
coeur diagonale qui étaient là pour
tenter sa chance dans toutes les dans
toutes les situations
alors je crois que il faut quand même
dire quelques mots de ce tournoi du
sénat cette organisation est en même
temps de mettre en perspective par
rapport au tournoi de bordeaux dont qui
avait été créée par stéphane laborde
ce qui n'est pas là ce soir mais qu'on
embrasse qui est à bordeaux et qui est
henri tu es si on essaye de monter canal
web maintenant véritablement tout un
circuit oui alors ça c'est l'objectif de
faire un diagonal tour avec avec canal
web avec diagonale là effectivement il
ya eu le grand prix de bordeaux
maintenance et on sait le faire ça fait
quatre ans que ça dure et que se
pérennise
là il ya cette première première chose
au grand prix du sénat effectivement
l'objectif étant de faire un circuit de
4 grands tournois avec évidemment une
belle finale qui intégrerait garry
kasparov
c'est des projets pour l'instant donc
l'actualité de cette semaine c'est quand
même le grand prix du sénat est donc une
belle belle prestation en tout cas beau
premier match d'ouverture le match
spassky contraire nos chars qui commence
par égalité à répétition alors on va
déjà vers harardhere peut-être en
quelques mots que ça se passe demi
finales finale il ya quatre joueurs et
c'est comme au tennis c'est à dire que
c'est la mort subite si on perd c'est
parti ça c'est un scoop à élimination
directe c'est-à-dire qu'une fois qu'on a
perdu on ne peut plus gagner le tournoi
il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas d'issue
de secours
donc la premier match maurice parce
qu'il rencontre arnaud hauchard très
chaud c'est les deux joueurs sont sont
très forts tous les deux
votre niveau et qui voilà c'est ça qu'on
a eu la chance au début le tirage au
sort qui avait été tirée en direct ici a
fait deux matches à peu près équilibrés
puisqu'il y avait le match se passe
qu'est au char de joie qui sont un peu
plus à 2000 2500 un peu plus de 1500
points aujourd'hui et deux joueurs qui
étaient à 2007 2006 donc assez
équilibrée et c'est vrai que
certainement
il y avait une certaine pression sur les
deux joueurs parce que ce pas ce qui
finalement ils jouent peut maintenant et
il a envie de montrer quand même bac il
est qu'il reste encore quelque chose du
grand spassky et puis pour hochart
s'éteint c'est un joueur sympathique ça
faisait une dizaine d'années qui courait
après le titre de grand maître
il vient de l'avoir enfin tout au moins
il va la voir dans les semaines qui
viennent et c'est pour lui une chance
effectivement de jouer devant un public
nombreux
oui très nombreux puisque la salle était
complètement pleines au sénat il y avait
250 personnes qui étaient là en
permanence pour tous les matches donc
effectivement c'était chaud match très
chaud ça commence deux joueurs quand
même assez solides pour espace qui est
connu et reconnu pour ça pour son son
humeur pacifiste son humeur gentil et
sympathique
arnaud hauchard également donc ça
commence tranquille bon boris spassky
obtient une position gagnante qu'il ne
transforme pas première partie nulle
deuxième partie nul donc blitz de
départage
alors là oui le grid c'est difficile
puisqu'on vous rappelle ses cinq minutes
au début d'avril ya deux de deux
penaltys on veut dire les blitz et les
penaltys d'un dans cette formule ou ont
chacun à chacun à 5 minutes et
évidemment ça devient très dur parce que
l'intuition jouent un plus grand rôle
oui ça c'est les blitz toujours moment
très très très très tendu très très
chaud puisque la gaffe et qu'un vite
arriver quand on réfléchit très peu et
là encore nouvelle égalité deux buts
nulle et là on arrive à la grande halle
au dénouement
ah bah là on a une anecdote parce
qu'effectivement abandonné faut que ça
s'arrête c'est comme dans un match de
football où un match de tennis fois
tie-break en été c'est le tie break et
on a trouvé une solution c'est pas si
c'est la meilleure mais c'est à dire que
les blancs doivent gagner
ils ont cinq minutes et les noirs n'ont
que quatre minutes mais s'ils font nul
qui gagne alors c'est évident on sait
pas on sait pas si c'est vraiment
équilibré dans un premier temps
l'arbitrage à la digit la 10e' tx tire
au sort
arnaud hauchard lo gagne il choisit
d'avoir les blancs mais en réalité il
n'a pas très bien compris le système
et puis ils changent et puis bah
racontent tous la fin
finalement arnaud hauchard n'avez pas
tout compris il a été pris de court il
savait plus trop quoi faire et
finalement donc sportif il a dit non
mais je joue pour gagner
je vais donc prendre les blancs dans
cette partie il a pris les blancs et là
est tombé sur un os puisque
effectivement aller chercher boris
spassky quand on vient de faire quatre
nuls que l'ambiance est quand même
annulant ce pacifiste et égalitaire
c'était un peu chaud de choisir les
blancs s'étaient très sportif de sa part
mais malheureusement il n'a pas réussi à
passer la muraille boris spassky donc
parties nulles et qualification du
champion du monde 1969 le mythique boris
spassky qu'ils aient joué contre fisher
ben alla tout à fait alors après la
deuxième demi-finale c'est on va dire
deux gladiateurs de des échecs
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire shirov quel
numéro 4 mondial qui est quand même l'un
des plus forts joueurs au monde actuel
et puis lautier qui est aussi un c'est
un dur sur l'échiquier bien entendu loti
est très fort très concentré toujours
très entraîné aussi puisqu'ils jouent
aux mélodies amber depuis des années
donc entraîné en semi rapide bon mais
effectivement shirov en ce moment
c'était vraiment l'homme en forme c'est
la massue le vraiment le colosse d échec
actuel
il remporte tous les tournois qui joue
dès qu'ils jouent un match ils gagnent
sur le score de 1-1 et demi 1/2 il gagne
tous ses matches pratiquement donc
c'était un match très très dur pour
notre numéro un français et il n'a pas
démérité puisque dans la première il a
fait nul avec les noirs assez facilement
et avec les pièces blanches je pense
qu'il a fait une gaffe dû à la pression
autant oui c'est ça moi j'ai vu ces
dames b6 on pourra pas voir la partie
puisqu'on en a choisi une autre mais la
force de shirov c'est qu'il est très en
forme donc qui met aussi en compétition
mais la pression tant à la pendule à
anjouan 25 minutes on le rappelle dans
cette poésie abandonné
on veut pas trop technique mais
je l avais joué une un système compliqué
contre la grüne feld un système on
pousse ses pions on prend le centre où
il a effectivement certainement pris une
bonne position a abandonné mais qui
demandait beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'investissements il a gaffé
il a fini par gaffes et donc shirov une
fois plus gagné un beau match un an et
demi 1/2 et donc là on arrive vers une
match pour la troisième place donc
franco français arnaud hauchard contre
joël lautier regard là qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire on peut dire qu'effectivement
arnaud est passé très près de l'exploit
1 parce qu'ils peuvent je sais pas si
c'était un exploit de battre parce qu'il
est aujourd'hui c'est pas le spy kids il
ya 230 ans évidemment mais pour lui ça
aurait été bien l'été passé je crois que
le lendemain matin ils étaient quand
même très fatigué alors il a joué contre
un joueur lautier qui est plus fort que
lui on peut pas aller contre ça et en
plus il était certainement fatigués et
on ne recherche c'est quand même un
homme qui vit la nuit principalement il
travaille la nuit
donc là il a eu du mal à se mettre dans
le rythme dans le rythme de ce tournoi
le premier match étant l'après midi ça
allait le deuxième match étant à 10
heures 30 le matin ça a été assez
difficile de se mettre en de se mettre
en condition d'être d'être bien chaud
pour le matin et donc effectivement
c'était délicat contre joël lautier
pourtant elle a passé de bonnes nuits je
crois il a passé une très bonne nuit il
était quand même à l'hôtel raphaël
partenaires du tournoi donc qui est à
deux pas de pad canal web puisque c'est
au 17 avenue kléber donc il a passé des
excellents puis probablement puisque
c'est quand même mais pas un désaveu
l'hôtel on veut dire peut-être deux
trois mots sur les gens qui nous ont
aidés alors évidemment canal web mon
canal web c'est la télé qui cros échec
avec cette émission avec des émissions
d'initiation ça vous le savez c'est le
sénat qui je crois a envie de jouer la
carte des échecs parce que justement il
ya canal web parce que c'est le mariage
d'une institution plus d'une d'une start
up et puis en l'occurrence les banques
populaires
une banque c'est ce qu'il nous fallait
non mais enfin qui ont joué le jeu et je
crois que comme et c'était le temps là
s'est bien déroulée je pense qu'on les
reverra
oui tout à fait donc ça évidemment c'est
bien entendu nos futurs partenaires pour
l'année prochaine si le circuit diagonal
tour venait à avoir lieu avant arnaud
hauchard à passer de bonnes nuits chez
notre partenaire le raphaël
malheureusement ça n'a pas suffi il perd
donc ce match se retrouvent donc 4e joël
lautier troisième et on arrive à la
grande finale
le match merveilleux qui fait rêver
puisque boris spassky l'ancien champion
alexei shirov l'homme des temps modernes
une belle affiche en tout cas alors je
crois qu'il faut d'abord dire qu'il y
avait beaucoup de monde
on avait une salle de 250 personnes elle
était pleine il ya eu des gens très bien
qui sont venus je crois avec toujours
avec une qualité d'écouté avec de
l'animation des commentaires avec l'aide
de casques infrarouge c'était une belle
fête et je crois que les gens étaient
contents de voir le vieux champion qui
était je crois oui elle était là avec sa
femme son fils et elle à son fils à 20
ans donc il n'a jamais connu du temps de
sa gloire
et puis shirov étaient venus aussi avec
sa femme et puis shirov lui bon il est
numéro quatre mondial il a arrêté là en
ligne de mire kasparov donc il n'a pas
le droit de perdre
oui effectivement mais enfin le public
avait clairement choisi son camp puisque
il y avait beaucoup de fans de boris
spassky puisqu'il est maintenant
français qu'il est très populaire ici et
donc le coeur du public battait pour
boris mais il semblerait que
malheureusement ça n'est pas suffi bon
il s'incline dans la première partie et
dans la deuxième la partie qu'on va
commenter tout à l'heure il obtient une
position pro l'on gagne en tu alors
gagnante on va l'analyser avec toi eloi
sarr que nous évidemment on apple
c'était une position en tout cas très
difficile où il a gagné une pièce mais
c'est là où on a vu aussi la force d'un
shirov aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'il a
réussi tout le temps a compliqué il a
gagné des pions pour la pièce il a
jamais laissé boris exprimer cette pièce
de plus c'est la marque des grands
champions quand même parce
qu'effectivement avec une position
quasiment désespérée contre un ex
champion du monde boris spassky réussir
encore y croire se battre et a
finalement arraché ce demi point
synonyme de victoire c'est un bel
exploit donc là effectivement donc un
très beau tournoi et vous pouvez bien
entendu venir le revoir sur les différer
de canal web tout les matchs sont
archivés un parent dont vous avez le
match en vidéo le fichier pgn sur la
plata côté et les commentaires de jean
luc chabanois jean-claude - qui était
très très bon aux commentaires elle vise
surtout à lille était très bon visées
sont essayés des techniques en même
temps d'être pas trop compliqué et puis
ils ont été aidés par les par les
champions il faut les remercier aussi
bien joël lautier aussi bien qu arnaud
hauchard qui sont venus en cabine tout
le temps pour pour animer
ces commentaires donc voilà donc vous
pouvez revivre ça sur la colonne différé
de diagonale dans la rubrique différé le
grand prix du le grand prix du sénat
2000 également donc ça pour conclure
cette ce tournoi il ya une remise des
prix est enrhumé en présence de
christian poncelet président du sénat
quand même le deuxième personnage de
l'état qui était là pour l'occasion il y
avait aussi jacques rosselin président
de canal web et ensuite tout le monde
les quatre champions sont sortis pour
aller faire profiter le public de leur
présence dans les jardins du luxembourg
alors oui ça c'était encore une fois il
sait des jardins du luxembourg
appartiennent au sénat a peu de gens le
savent
on sait qu'une dans les jardins du
luxembourg il ya une tradition ça fait
maintenant une vingtaine d'années que
les à côté des tennis il ya de sport il
ya un sport physique un sport de
l'esprit
les gens venaient pour jouer aux échecs
comme ça sur des petits échiquier et
puis à vrai dire le conseiller du
président du sénat est un fort joueur
d'échecs
il s'est dit tiens est faux mais des
échiquiers et puis jouent ils jouent et
puis là il y avait 60 échiquier et les
gens tu l'as vu eloi bas se battait pour
jouer contre les champions 1 1 il ya vu
et puis on dit que c'est pas populaire
il y avait des enfants il y avait des
femmes
on dit aussi qu'il ya pas assez de
femmes y avait pas mal de femmes qui
jouait il y avait des forts joueurs des
moins fort joueurs et ça a duré deux
heures il faisait beau et il faisait
beau donc la magie du jeu d'échecs dans
ses jardins du luxembourg
beaucoup de joueurs qui sont fans du jeu
ça a vraiment donné une superbe
manifestation chacun avait son style
arnaud char qui a pris son temps qui a
fait mûrir ses positions alexei shirov
qui a expédié ses adversaires picoraient
il courait alexei shirov qui était en
train de courir donc il y avait quatre
champions quatre styles donc un très
beau spectacle en tout cas dans ses
jardins du luxembourg pour clore pour
clôturer en fait cette second prix du
sénat 2000 très bien alors j'espère que
ça ne sera pas le dernier
et puis de toute façon on sait que le
prochain ça sera à bordeaux on est sûr
de bordeaux déjà puisqu'on a réservé les
dates refn l'avoir nous l'a dit et puis
je crois que maintenant ce qu'on a envie
de voir c'est une partie c'est peut-être
alors on a choisi la la partie entre
shirov espèces qui la deuxième salle où
sa nourrice aurait pu revenir donc on va
lancer la deuxième rubrique de diagonale
l'actuel la partie de la semaine
voilà donc partis ont redit donc c'est
la finale c'est parce qu'ils dans la
première partie avait les blancs il a
joué passivement et c'était 1 c'était
pas une partie passionnante mais ces
temps on a on a vu comme un champion un
grand champion ce pas ce qu'était est un
ex grand champion s'ils jouent
passivement contre un gars de la force
ii shirov aujourd'hui qui est un gars
qui joue à 2755 avec matt uchronique 2-0
face et c'est un super champion il faut
pas jouer passivement aux échecs il a en
tout cas ça n'a pas payé on a vu une
technique fantastique die zeit shirov
qui est probablement le plus grand
technicien mondiale il a composé des
études de finale c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs de finale au monde et dans cette
variante plus ou moins une variante des
changes de la française ou tousser
changer très vite l'avantagent semblait
minimum dans cette finale deux tours
joël lautier pensé que c'était nul tout
le monde pensait que c'était nul
alexei shirov à profiter toutes les
imperfections et a fini par remporter
une finale deux tours
scipion contre 6 incroyable donc score
après la première partie 1-0 pour alexei
shirov mais boris spassky avec les noirs
dos au mur objet de gagner donc ils
allaient noir shirov joue à eux quatre
or c'est un bon joueur et il pouvait
jouer plus solide a eu quatre il n'a pas
peur à aux caps et mons et le coup de
girofle chiante jour régulièrement ce
coup là de toute façon au niveau on peut
dire que tous les coudes valent aussi
bien des 4,4 tous les joueurs jouent
tous les coups
kasparov le premier alexei shirov
préfère un u 4 il joue agressif il
envoie aux 4 boris spassky g7 g6
alors moi ce que je peux dire on va on
va passer rapidement sur les coûts de
début parce que c'est pas très théorique
mais justement c'est ce que cherche
boris aujourd'hui travail - il est à
meudon
non ça va dans une ville où il ya des
russes je crois qu'il est à la retraite
il le dit lui-même tout le temps donc il
essaie de trouver les systèmes qui sont
moins analysé
j'avais joué il ya de ça deux ans à côté
de lui à bastia elle avait joué un b 6
oui jouer à b6 tout le temps donc quand
l'été cherche des systèmes qui sont
moins analysé et vous allez voir la
partie très original puisque au 10e coup
c'est déjà le bal complet effectivement
alors mon chez 6 l'idée de ce coup voilà
on va résumer cette ouverture il veut
mettre le fou angers7 le fou noir sur sa
grande diagonale ici angers7
ça c'est l'idée de ce que m'enfin c'est
une idée minimum l'idée c'est surtout 1
sortir des sentiers battus puisque
effectivement boris n'est plus n'est
plus au top de la théorie n'est plus à
la pointe de la technologie et chicken
qui reflue giraud fort vent est un grand
spécialiste des ouvertures bien entendu
donc il veut déjà sortir shirov deux
versions et 2 ne pas donner
d'opportunité simple à son adversaire de
faire nul dire que boris spassky ici
encore il veut gagner le match
il refuse une nulle sur le soit enfin il
refuse de perdre le match a émis 1 2 me
il va jouer jusqu'au bout donc il va
jouer un système assez rampon pas trop
de contacts
il va jouer fond de court de loin en
attendant qu'il se passe des choses et
en espérant qui va réussir à trouver
quelque chose mais de toute façon quand
shirov c'est pas gagné avec les noirs si
on reprend le centre sa logique donc
pour grand principe de l'ouverture
prenait le centre fou g7 sans surprise
pour boris spassky troisième coup kelly
c 3 rien à dire sur ces coups là je
pense que c'est vraiment moderne
ouverture moderne des six cavaliers f3
donc développement très classique on se
croirait à l'école
les cavaliers vont sur les bonnes cases
on sent les cavaliers avant les fous et
on prend le centre d'art h voilà rien à
dire d'autre
c'est tous les bons coups et laboris
voilà là ça commence 90e 6
personnellement je n'ai jamais vu ça je
sais pas trop d'où ça sort
c'est très souple c'est très souple
alors vous allez on appelle ça il va
jouer à 6 après h is on appelle ça
certains appellent ça la défense
hippopotames c'est à dire que vous savez
l'hippopotame il est dans un lac et on
voit plus que ses oreilles et c'est un
peu ça c'est à dire que les lois vont
jouer sur la 6ème ranger ils attendent
c'est où le hérisson fayyad
mais c'est l'hippopotame c'est la vie
photo yves déry leçon on a échangé un
pion avant de la csla va en typo tam
donc voilà c'est très c'est très chaud
et l'a donc au 5e ou déjà ça commence
alexei shirov très chaud très énervé par
cette conception un peu étrange
étonnante puisque boris spassky pâte
contact rien que se passe-t-il 5e coup h
4 h 2 h 4 il envoie on adore ça
balsillie a fait c'est c'est ce qu'on
appelle des parties s'est départi les
mauvaises langues diront que ce sont des
parties de café mais c'est vrai que les
deux joueurs ont été achetés bon dans
cette position parce que c'est le jeu
des noix est quand même un peu passif
donc on peut se permettre d'essayer de
deux d'attaquer tout de suite allé droit
oui l'idée de ce coup c'est que les
blancs vont bien entendu faire le grand
roque mettre le roi du côté gauche de
l'échiquier
alors que les noirs donc là en fait le
but de secouer d'interdire au noir le
petit rock
il faut mieux prévenir que guérir ici
après un coup comme elles doivent certes
on n'a plus envie d'aller rocqué petit
côté avec les noirs donc c'est un coup
pour se prévenir contre ça et là boris
spassky 13 à zhuhai h6 viendrait de
l'hippopotame qui sortent toujours très
très souple donc toujours très souple on
a laissé shirov n'oublie pas le
développement des pièces faut 3 alors
que boris spassky lui toujours continuer
c'est la deuxième c'est la bm
vous voyez c'est un peu pour ça qu'on a
choisi cette partie nous les légères
pour l'ouverture qui est totalement
extravagante est assez incroyable moi je
j'ai vu beaucoup de parties d'échecs
d'aidé comme ça j'en ai vu rarement on
se demande ce que fait brice parce
qu'ici en tout cas alexei shirov lui
sort toutes ces pièces donc la voyez ça
continue comme à l'école le formation
très droit très classique
les fous viennent sur les cases centrale
est bon est ce parce qu'il vit joue
bessette b5 donc toujours un coup à
droite un coup à gauche je vais me
permettre une petite réflexion je sais
pas ce qui s'était un jour au style très
classique quand il était plus jeune
superbe style un super je suis vraiment
classée juste d'une certaine manière
c'était lui qui jouait comme shirov et
je crois que les champions ont vieilli
on vit de créer des choses différentes
et il y avait un cas comparable avec
steinitz
au siècle dernier qui avait eu un style
aussi très positionnelle très classique
et qui à la fin de sa vie s'amuse et
ajustements rampe et derrière c'est et
on essaye c'est à dire qu'évidemment à
partir d'un certain âge on a envie de
créer et je crois qu'ici bon ils
poussent ils poussent presque oui mais
on va voir la suite de la partie je
crois qu'à pas y'a rien analysé ici
n'ont pour l'instant il n'y a aucune
garantie concrète qui se présentent
les blancs ont de multiples choix alexei
shirov choisi une percée central alex
est sûre veut un peu de un peu de
contacts joue au huitième coup le coup
eux 4 5 qui est déjà un coup critique
mais si c'est peut-être ça que voulait
ce parce qu'il s'est elle accueillit les
nerfs une certaine je crois que c'est
très psychologique qu'ils aient envie
que l'autre fasse quelque chose et c'est
un peu ce que les chinois recherchent et
oui on peut comparer ça à un boxeur qui
baisse pas sa garde
voilà il n'a sorti aucune pièce il
attend il attend il devance son
adversaire fous ils bougent un peu et
finalement avec ces chirurgies au 5 et
la boris spassky donc toujours très zen
sans le fou en baisse est donc l'avouer
les dauphins noirs en bessette et g7
contrôler les deux grandes diagonales
donc ça c'est très bon c'est très très
bon parce que donc ce qui est inclus
dans ces deux grandes diagonales seller
quand même les cases centrale et ça ça
c'est ça c'est la clé la clé d une
partie d'échecs
les quatre classes vertes au centre donc
ici les deux footballs ris parce qu'ils
sont armés pour aller là dessus et les
fous sont complémentaires ici on voit
déjà des menaces éventuellement qui
pourrait être par exemple puis on prend
pions puis on prend pions fou prend
cavaliers suivi de fou prend pions ça
c'est une des idées monde actuellement
ça ne marche pas mais il commence à y
avoir des idées commencent à y avoir
danger dam des deux est là boris spassky
maintenant met la pression sur le pion
aux 5 il a trouvé une cible en fait avec
ce chiffre les données une cible très
simple c'est ce pion eu cinq donc
maintenant vous voyez que toutes les
pièces de avec ses chiens
le cavalière de cette le fond g7 et
l'option des six sont tous braqués
oui les pièces de ce parce qu'ils sont
braqués vers le seul pions blancs qui a
osé s'aventurer je dirais on verra
edit en deux mots étaient en train de le
dire que ce parce qu' alors est un peu
son adversaire c'est qu'il a fait croire
qu'il s'intéressait pas aux santons
ayant été s'occupe vraiment du centre il
faut pas qu'on s'est un peu didactique
au fond il n'a pas oublié non il n'a pas
oublié que le centre était la clé du jeu
d'échecs et ici il met une telle
pression sur ses pions blancs qui a trop
avancé qu' ils forcent alexei shirov à
faire un échange un échange que alexei
shirov ne voulait bien entendu pas faire
pour une raison je dirais arithmétique
l'option qui est ici c'est à bouger
trois fois alors que l'option de boris
qui était sur la case la même case
n'avait bougé qu'une fois donc pour des
raisons stand de calcul
alexei shirov dans cet échange a perdu
de temps donc voilà donc ici déjà bonne
opération pour boris spassky toi qu'est
ce que tu penses ici tu penses que déjà
final un espace qui s'est pas mal
débrouillé
on dira express qui s'est pas mal
débrouillé maintenant effectivement
toutes les pièces blanches ont sorti les
blancs n'ont pas fait de faute dans
cette position
les blancs n'ont pas de faiblesse donc
bon la position reste ouverte bien
entendu mais si j'avais le choix ici je
préférerais jouer côté noir quand ça m'a
l'air plus plus souple et plus que
logique tout ça 11e coup des cinq de
nouveau un pion débarque au centre bon
est-ce que menace quand même menace
menace assez direct on s'attaque aux
cases blanches pions prend pion aux 6es
si l'option est revient pour prendre
ainsi le pion g6 se retrouve sans
protection est directement prise par le
fou détroit donc ça ça fait une menace
bien entendu boris parce qu'il n'y a pas
envie de prendre en d5 puisqu'à ce
moment là il se retrouverait avec
d'options doublé donc s'il prenait sur
cette case ici en dé 5,6 et boris
spassky qui est allé chercher ce pion ça
ne serait pas bon puisqu'on aurait
d'options doublé sur colonne ouverte
ça c'est un principe il faut absolument
éviter ça puisque les pions sur la
colonne se font tout simplement
proprement manger les uns après les
autres
donc ça c'est pas une bonne chose donc
ici bord espèce qui est obligé de réagir
puisque l excellent shirov menace de
prendre l'ue ne peut pas prendre il faut
donc s'en aller il joue en deuxième coup
de 6,5 avec maintenant une idée très
simple jouet f5 puis e 4 on se croirait
dans une interview
il ya longtemps une bonne vieille et
steria alexei shirov maintenant joue h5
et là problème problème pour l'excellent
shirov puisque donc une fois de plus ce
problème pour boris spassky jeu je ne
sais pas pourquoi j'ai l'impression que
si on fait les noirs donc l'option et
angers 6 il est attaqué par le plus rage
c'est peut-être parce que shirov est
capable de jouer parfois comme ça avec
les noirs là c'est une des spécialités
de chez rough cette ouverture c'est pour
ça on ne sait plus qui joue mais comment
qui les jouent pourquoi c'est un peu le
flou artistique en ce moment h 5 et l'a
donc menace on n'a pas envie d'avancer
le pion ce pion angers 6 on ne veut pas
le maître angers 5 parce que s'affaiblir
et les cases blanches
on va faire en jaune ici tout un
complexe de cases blanches qui
deviendrait faible donc on ne veut pas
avancer ce projet fils d'un autre côté
on ne peut pas le tenir ici puisque
vallée de alexei shirov cette fois qu'il
est blanc menace de prendre il faut
trouver une solution et boris parce
qu'ils trouvent une solution assez
violente c'est à dire que l'option g6
n'était défendu que par le pion à 7
elle essaye shirov enlève la défense il
joue au fc f5 et donc 10 est un coup
très esthétique ça entraînait les pour
aller le principe des structures de
pions un ici finalement c'est une partie
est superbe quand même parce qu'il joue
il joue alors théorie il ya des attaques
de flan et au centre parce que c'est et
puis en même temps on sacrifie tout de
suite enfin c'est quand même complexe
effectivement alors oui là ce qu'il peut
voir c'est que boris spassky à renverser
la vapeur
au début c'est les blancs qui avaient
d'options au centre et maintenant qu'ils
allaient pion au centre et bien c'est
boris avec les pions e55 il a pris le
centre et il fait une menace directe
ils menacent e 5 e 4 avec une bonne
vieille fourchette ouï dire attaque le
foot est roi et le cas il ya en fait
trois en même temps double aval à une
attaque double web simplement 4 et il ya
également voilà l'autre coup bien tout à
fait tout à fait ici le coup f5 f4 donc
en fait multiples menaces avec souk où
il crée des menaces dans tous les sens
bourg il se passe alexei shirov s'en
sort très faible coût cavaliers h4
contre attaques ça c'est un coup
difficile quand même fait c'est un coup
difficile mais d'un autre côté qui est
déjà forcé puisque déjà devant
l'affluence des menaces noir on n'a plus
trop le choix du cavalier h4 une partie
assez dur a commenté pascal et trek mais
retiennent cavaliers de cette vos rides
se défend et cette fois ci il ne joue
donc
plus pour le coup aux 5,4 puisque ça ne
fait plus de fourchette ce n'était plus
d'attac double mais il joue
effectivement pour le coup f5 f4 qui
enferme le fond ou trois qui n'a plus de
cases sur l'échiquier donc menace again
pièces et d'ailleurs c'est chose faite
puisque l'excellent scheer officines ne
trouve pas de solution il joue h 30 j'ai
six f4 le fou est enfermé triste au sort
pour le pour le fouet et c'est beau
c'est un oui effectivement
par contre voilà shirov donc là c'est
voilà il va perdre une pièce dont par
une pièce c'est perdre la partie c'est
pareil il faut donc trouver des il faut
trouver des arguments un pion il ya déjà
il a déjà l'air est un pion voyez faut
compter les là il peut en prendre deux
autres ici il peut jouer fou prend f4
par exemple pour un f4
mais il trouve un coup intermédiaire
assez esthétique au 15e coup cavaliers
vient à eux quatre ici attaque donc
l'option des six avec échec puisque si
on prend ce qu'ils ont fait et chaque
courant ça c'est une menace assez
désagréable on n'a pas envie de se
laisser plonger en échec puisque une
fois que le roi a bougé on rappelle
qu'on peut plus rauque et ça c'est une
mauvaise chose parce que évidemment le
rock c'est le meilleur moyen de se
protéger
donc refus par boris spassky qui très
tranquille dit je défends mon pions
toute façon on s'en fout ne peut pas
sortir le faux 3 ne peut toujours pas
sortir et c'est sur ça qu'il joue
cavalier banquiers cheikh fou prend et
maintenant c'est l'heure de fou pour un
f4 il n'y a plus d'autre solution il
faut prendre les pions pions prend 3,4
et là je pense qu'on peut reprendre
notre souffle un petit peu voilà on se
calme là il faut faire un bilan
il faut faire un bilan ici qu'est ce qui
s'est passé les blancs ont trois pions
pour la pièce il suffit de les compter
les noirs dont 4 les blancs dont 7 3
pions pour la pièce ils ont une position
assez menaçante puisqu'on voit que le
roi noir semble et papa encore ok il ya
ce option g6 qui est très avancé dans le
camp blanc donc qui est susceptible de
faire des menaces directes et dangereuse
donc a priori ça a l'air bien pour les
blancs mais boris a vu un petit détail
plus loin c'est à dire que dans cette
position le fauve s'ils s'étaient
attaqués mais il a une défense qui
attaque et qui défend même temps un coup
parfait cavaliers promotion des 5
donc là il ya une pièce pour deux pions
une pièce pour d'options
et ici qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il
ya une inde en chêne mans fort ces dames
f3 dame cet échec échec au roi donc ici
il faut bouger droit roi f1 et la voilà
je pense est dans cette position que
simplement que les noirs sont
complètement gagnant alors comment alors
comment fait ce n'était pas facile quand
même nous on a vu la partie en direct
évidemment on avait d'autres choses à
faire mais ce n'était pas facile
ici on est surtout en 25 minutes et on
rappelle que c'est quand même de la
partie semi rapides c'est des parties
semi-rapides effectivement là ici déjà
les joueurs ont déjà réfléchi beaucoup
pour arriver dans cette position donc la
pendule étant ce qu'elle est
c'est-à-dire que le temps tourne dans un
seul sens il est incompressible
il faut il faut garder du temps pour
pouvoir jouer les coups physiquement sur
l'échiquier
il faut donc je vais vite il faut
prendre une décision rapide est ici je
pense que notre ami boris boris spassky
donc c'est tromper n'a pas vu la bonne
option il fallait jouer cavalier b4 dans
cette position on peut mentionner la
variante le cahier des cinq ans b 4 ce
coût n'a pas été joué mais je pense que
c'était le coup gagnant dans cette
position l'idée l'idée est très simple
le foot mais cette attaque la dame est
roi le cavaly b4 va prendre au coude
après le foot est roi puisque la dame va
bouger c'est sûr on va prendre ce fou
detroit une fois qu'on aura pris de fous
là on aura
il faudra compter différemment ça sera
plus de deux pions pour une pièce mais
deux pions et de fou enfin il y aura
deux fous contre vingt cavaliers
d'options et ça c'est très dur parce que
de fou c'est très efficace et ça aurait
été vraiment très très durs le fourbe et
7 va jouer un rôle terrible va être
extrêmement fort alors que dans la
partie dont boris a joué au 20e courant
roc il n'a pas été chercher le foot est
roi et ça va lui poser des très très
gros problème il fallait prendre se fout
des 3 donc là je pense que c'est là
c'est vraiment le moment critique
position 20e coup que boris spassky a
raté la chance de revenir dans le match
d'égaliser le score et
souvient un peu de ce moment je crois
qu'il a beaucoup réfléchi à ce moment là
il va beaucoup réfléchi choix qu'il a dû
prendre 5 à 10 minutes pour une cadence
comme ça c'est beaucoup
effectivement il a certainement pensé à
un coût normal enfin coût normal c'est à
cacher son roi la sécurité de son roi
mais il fallait d'abord et finalement il
changer les pièces
c'est un autre grand principe quand on
arrivait de l'avant ce nom mais là c'est
vrai qu'on voit la force du champion du
monde de l'ex champion du monde sait que
intuitivement même sans travailler c'est
à dire que même complètement bourré il
aurait quand même senti que le moment où
il fallait réfléchir c'était celui-là
c'est ça sa maintenance et il est
intégré ça c'est une seconde nature chez
lui il sait il dise en quelle est la
position critique
maintenant ils trouvent pas forcément la
solution avant il aurait bien entendu
trouver habite maintenant donc les
choses étant ce qu'elles sont on voit
qui s'est trompé coup au 20e courant roc
est une faute ce qui permet alexei
shirov maintenant de mettre le feu à
l'échiquier le pyromane là les fidèles à
la lorraine de l'échec donc ça commence
par tour
un petit coup tranquille taurin donc
menace très simple on attaque la dame
boris intercepte cette menace avec fouet
f6 ans le 5 est maintenant le fameux fou
détroit dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure le fou détroit qui qu'on aurait
dû éliminer se réveille et vient sur la
case e 4 l' attaque le cahier des cinq
donc cavalier f6 tout à fait fort c'est
ça a été vu avec joël lautier boris
parce qu'ils jouent maintenant qu'elle
10 h 4 ans f5 shirov chiroque j avais
h45 chirurgicale 10 h45 je vais arrêter
de dire le nom des fleurs ça sera plus
simple
les noirs jouent dams est cette fois
tombé cet échec dame français
d'apprendre ça donc éduquer audi s5 y
ait un coup intermédiaires et maintenant
j'ai 6 j'essaie fameux pions nouveau
coup intervient et puis la torah chien
qui n'a jamais vu bouger mes questions
une colonne semi ouverte
mais qui donc va jouer la tourache un
ici jouent un rôle très efficace donc là
encore un coup pour hg vite très logique
de se mettre devant lyon et maintenant
alexei shirov jouent tous rachats
trempions h 10 personnellement pendant
la partie je pensais que c'était une
erreur
je ne sais pas je n'aurai pas permis au
noir de jouer dans mon programme
j'aurais été j'ai moi-même chercher la
dame en bessette
pour éviter justement d'avoir le plonger
qui vient sur la sur la colonne f
maintenant effectivement ce que alexei
shirov à penser c'est très simple c'est
que il préfère laisser le roi ans et
beat
c'est dire que si c'est lui qui joue
d'un programme leroy ans et 8 va
reprendre et ne sera plus sur cette case
nous qui préfèrent le laisser là
pourquoi parce que lecavalier en test au
f5 de sauter sur la case au set ferrer
chèque et une fourchette donc ramassé la
qualité ça c'est l'idée maintenant
question de timing
mais c'est toujours très délicat à dire
voilà c'était pas facile
là c'est pas facile du tout d'un
programme son programme est là donc les
blancs menace tout simplement tout
reprend cavaliers et puis avec une
centaine de cavaliers aux 7 laux si les
blancs menace qui vit au 7 mai ça c'est
pas la menace la plus grave dans cette
position parce que cavaliers au cet
échec
on va bouger le roi le cavalier va venir
prendre la tour la tour va venir prendre
et ensuite le pion g7 sera perdue donc
là la clé de cette position pour les
blancs c'est ce pion angers7
changer cette île et il est très très
fort ils vont plus qu' il vaut plus
qu'une tour actuellement puisqu'ils
n'ont en fait il vaut une tour
puisqu'ils monopolise complètement la
tour g8
il faut absolument pas donner ce projet
c'est la menace très logique des blancs
dans cette position je pense que c'est
tour eu un prof ou au cinquième
ça c'est beaucoup de choses voilà il ya
il commencera demain sont tous les sens
et le cavalier cet échec
y'a tout reprend 1,5 il ya les coûts
tranquille donc ici c'est assez délicat
pour boris je crois qu'on avait pensé
donc là je vous invite vraiment vous
référez si vous voulez vous en savoir
plus sur cette partie elle est commentée
par joël lautier dans les différer
diagonale mais je crois que c'était
cavaliers des simples coups le coût
auquel on avait pensé avec joël qui
semblait être un bon coup dans cette
position en tout cas c'est très
difficile très difficile à jouer pour
boris et il choisit dans le doute je me
rappelle de mon entraîneur qui me dit ça
quand tu ne sais pas quoi faire il faut
prendre et je crois ici voilà boris ne
savais plus quoi faire il a décidé de
prendre un pion puisque un pion c'est
toujours un pion et s'adresse doha bravo
un pion est toujours réaction donc ici
on peut faire ça il a joué un coup très
fort je crois il a joué tour 6 1 oui à
leur tour aussi c'est je me rappelle
encore de cette remarque de joël lautier
parce que je suis en fait beaucoup
réfléchi ici il avait cinq minutes il
réfléchit deux minutes deux minutes
entières donc sur cinq pratiquement la
moitié de son temps et je la dis moi si
j'avais les blancs se fait belle lurette
que je rejouais tours 6 au 28e ou le
coup que finalement shirov a choisi donc
pour elle elle expliqué c'est j'ai
entendu effectivement au 6e commenté
elle explique que finalement shirov
cherche toujours un c'est ça aussi la
force de ses joueurs c'est qui même
quand ils ont une des coûts évident ou
des positions évidente
ils cherchent et c'est pour ça qu
effectivement on l'appelle bon pourquoi
on l'appelle le pyromane de l'échiquier
est ce qu'il écrit un superbe bouquin
qui s'appelle fire on board le feu sur
l'échiquier en français où effectivement
s'est émerveillé parce qu'il ne joue que
des systèmes compliqués et wii nommé
shirov c'est un joueur un joueur de ce
spectacle qui en ont fait le spectacle
toujours il envoie toutes ces pièces
dans tous les sens d'ailleurs il ya une
confrontation qui était attendu qui n'a
pas eu lieu à ce compris du sénat
s'était alexei shirov contre arnaud
bouchard très attendu pourquoi parce que
justement dans ce fameux livre de shirov
ils analysent ces deux parties qu'il a
jouées contre arnaud hauchard et ces
deux festivals de combinaisons en
hochart jouant très défensive très
solide
alexei shirov l'attaqué à tout-va
sacrifie une tour puis une pièce dans la
partie suivante sacrifie deux tours puis
la dame puis un fou tout ça pour mater
donc arnaud enfin toujours des parties
très chaude entre ces deux joueurs cette
confrontation de styles lc shirov de
toute façon est un joueur très chaud
toujours à la recherche du meilleur coût
il arrête jamais de chercher ils
trouvent ils trouvent des études
fabuleuse je me rappelle de sa partie
contre topalov le couffo h3 mettant le
feu aux prises dans une finale qu'elle
se trouve le seul four gagner qui était
totalement fabuleux enfin si on n'a pas
la position à vous montrer en référence
mais donc tournant aussi c'est le coup
logique
alexei shirov l'a bien
bien réfléchi bien calculer il voulait
être sûr que ça soit ça il joue donc
tout revient aussi la menace maintenant
est très simple c'est de jouer tout
reprendre si ce qui simplifiera qui
simplifiera la position après le pion g7
volera de loin la qualité et faire
exactement est ici j'étais assez surpris
du coup de boris puisqu'il n'apparaît
cette menace il aurait pu jouer au 28e
coup cavaliers des cinq qui une fois de
plus le coup n'avait envisagé en cabine
de commentaires en direct avec joël
lautier mais c'est dangereux c'est
dangereux bien sûr mais là il faut quand
même gagner il faut gagner cette partie
après roy ses sept tours h prend f6 fou
prend f6 tourcoing f6 on arrive dans une
position qui s'annonce quand même
extrêmement difficile à gagner pour pour
boris ça va être très très dur parce que
maintenant et blanc ont un plan très
simple c'est de monter le roi ça c'est
un des plans possible de monter le roi
voilà je trace un chemin au hasard
jusqu'en g6 et ensuite gagner simplement
avec casillas 6 ou cabello 7 ça c'est un
plan pour coiffer pourquoi est-ce que ça
marcherait simplement parce que les
noirs ont bien trois pions contre deux
côté gauche de l'échiquier
mais ce n'est pas utilisable sais pas tu
dis ça parce qu'on peut pas créer deux
ans ont passé et ont passé c'est un pion
qui avance sans qui pleurait devant lui
ici vous voyez que la configuration
étant ce qu'elle est on n'arrive pas à
aller à dame avec les pions et ça c'est
un problème énorme
c'est le problème de boris spassky dans
cette position avec les noirs c'est
qu'il n'a pas de contre je donc les
blancs ont libre libre au chant sur le
souhaite tout ce qui va se passer
ils ont peut-être un petit avantage mais
les blancs russie liban sont
probablement un petit peu mieux donc il
a joué un coup très très solide donc là
tout a basculé
elle a fait une petite nous à ce moment
là où il allait la tête quatre journées
et on sentait qu'ils pourrissent parce
qu'ils n'étaient plus
savait qu'il n'était maligne on savait
que ça avait basculé que ça n'allait
plus il ya eu 6
on peut parler de la salle je me suis
dit c'est de les gens étaient déçus on a
entendu aussi un petit murmures dans la
salle parce qu'ils ont compris ses ex
pasquier aujourd'hui moi j'ai déjà
remarqué que par rapport à sa jeunesse
il joue toujours très bien positionné
lmnp mais en terme de calcul il va pas
au fond comme avant et donc là il
fallait qu'il ait certainement au fond
et comme il a pu beaucoup d'entraînement
n'a c'est peut-être qu'on perd le plus
saint éloi voyez passer ça c'est
effectivement quand on joue moins aux
échecs
ce qui fait défaut c'est le calcul c'est
allé loin dans les variantes être précis
ne pas oublier de coûts et surtout avoir
confiance
mais on a beau de toute évidence boris
spassky quand ils jouent contre shirov a
pas confiance en son calcul il sait que
l'autre a tout vu et ça c'est très très
difficile de jouer en se disant ça c'est
même quasiment impossible c'est pour ça
que dans les complications
il a cherché des échanges des
simplifications voilà alors que s'il
aurait dû
il réduit encore compliquer la position
puisque c'étaient les meilleurs coups
mais maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de compliqué contre un joueur
comme shirov qui va tout voir telle une
telle une machine
s'il ya un seul embranchements qui est
bon pour lui il va tout de suite se
trouvait donc boris spassky a peur
d'oublier des choses chercher des
simplifications et ça a donné cette
finale malheureuse qui maintenant va
être très très difficile
mais surtout je crois que c'est ça
shirov on va voir le dernier coup à
jouer un coup tout de suite pk nul tout
de suite il a joué un coup là-bas shirov
c'est pourquoi il est là il n'est pas là
pour gagner ces matches 2 0 ou faire
déçu comment il est là pour gagner le
match gagné le tournoi elhadj torah
fuites donc la difficile pour boris d'y
échapper
il faut prendre ce projet cette solution
g7 est devenu trop dangereux il n'y a
pas d'autre solution donc tour j'ai
plongé sept cavaliers prend g7 au projet
là on est dans une finale deux tours où
les blancs et en plus c'est un plan plus
symbolique puisque cette option doublé
donc pas très efficace mais
effectivement les noirs ne sont pas
mieux sont pas mieux puisque ils ont
voilà ils ont toujours pas deux ans
passés il n'y a pas de danger donc ici
comme c'est le spectacle comme il ya
toujours possibilité d'une gaffe comme
shirov n'a plus de deux minutes quand
même ça ça mérite d'être joué
boris spassky a continué il a joué
trente troisième coup f4 ou à ses six f
donc là alexei shirov a les idées très
claires en finale c'est à dire qu'il
avance ses pions il va en s'empirant
l'occurrence trois des cinq tours habite
maintenant ça y est mon c'est trop je
dirais trop facile dans cette position
de la grille vers nulle alain carré n'y
a pas deux il ya aucun suspense il
attaque le pion à 6 ce pion ne peut plus
être défendu tour c'est cette échoué au
35e coup tours pension à 6 tours
préemption ces deux monts là il ya de
moins en moins deux pions alexei jour
ag2 boris spassky jour où 1,5 mais voit
bien clairement qui s'il n'y a plus
aucun espoir dominé cette partie pour
shirov c'est très simple il a plus qu'à
jouer à six f-16 à fuite ou alors dès
que le roi noir s'en va prendre l'option
des six donc c'est très simple à jouer
l'annuler conclu dans cette position
victoire du tournoi pour un excellent
shirov baril alors qu'est quel est ton
bilan de ce tournoi en question de forme
des joueurs donc shirov quand même très
fort et que vient quand même de gagner
monaco 1 monaco où il ya tous les
meilleurs joueurs du monde sauf sauf
kasparov 1
bon ce pas ce qui je crois qu'il était
content parce qu'ils ont vraiment été
très longtemps il a fait un match très
très beau en tout cas très très
palpitant pour le public contre arnaud
hauchard ensuite contre l'excellent
shirov il obtenu cette très très belle
position qu'il a pas su transformer donc
boris spassky un retour raisonnable
joël alors joël il est tombé sur un os
puisqu'il a vu shirov au premier tour
très très difficile joël je ne sais pas
trop quelle est sa forme actuelle je
sais qu'il est très très fluctuant en ce
moment un coup ils jouent bien coup il
ajouté il joue mal en tout cas il est
toujours capable du meilleur et du pire
ça on le sait ici c'était un joël qui a
battu arnaud chat assez facilement qui a
perdu contre aix et shirov assez assez
facilement si on peut le dire bêtement
bêtement vêtements donc ton en demi
teinte pour choix là et puis arnaud
belle nous a fait plaisir quand même on
aurait été content d'être de jouer ce
tournoi il a fait un beau très beau
match contre boris ensuite il a joué
contre l'ol s'était c'était dur donc
arnaud arnaud en forme en forme toujours
en ce moment rien à dire de spécial
non je pense qu'on peut revenir
peut-être sur un petit bilan sur cette
partie là qui est quand même une partie
d'une extrême complexité
coxyde et la complexité et l'eau à
l'extrême complexité donc avec donc
boris qui a qui a extrait il n'y a pas
eu beaucoup de variantes puisque si on
commence à en commenter une flore tout
les expliquer là ça va plus être
possible
et puis bon c'est de ces du smur à pizza
qui voit pas tout non plus hein ils
voient pas tout non plus je crois
qu'être c'est moi je me souviens de toi
il ya de ça quelques années tu avais y
avait une soirée chez à nathalie baye
zale y'avait shirov et avait joué on
joue en partie rapide y avait des parts
est extraordinaire et a fait ni
d'ailleurs contraint shirov me voyais
pas tout non ce qui est ce qu'on peut
dire moi ce que je vois chez ces
champions c'est qu'ils ont une capacité
à créer surtout chez shirov beaucoup
beaucoup de complexité justin beaucoup
c'est difficile de jouer contre un gars
qui cherche qui cherche qui cherche
voyez nom et alexei shirov effectivement
donc je me rappelle de cette partie mais
j'avais fait nul contre x et shirov
c'était pour moi très très bien on leur
demande une grosse performance même si
c'était dans une soirée où tout le monde
est un peu joyeux et l'ambiance était
bonne c'est toujours un beau souvenir de
faire nul contre contre un joueur de
cette place en tout cas effectivement
effectivement ça joue bien ça joue très
complexe et ici bon bah parties
participent tous à la question quand
même qu'on peut se poser puisque bon
c'est quand même super en revanche pour
nous on est on est on est joyeux en tant
qu'organisateur c'est quand même suspect
ce qui revient aux charges joue pas mal
lautier bon malheureusement c'est notre
avis mais il va faire mieux et puis
shirov le plus fort gagne alors shirov
quand est-ce qu'il va jouer contre
kasparov
parce que c'est ça quand on est numéro
quatre mondial on a on a on a envie de
gagner contre ce pas ce qui c'est sûr
mais on a aussi envie de jouer contre
eux kasparov alors effectivement c'est
le débat est toujours là c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont alexei shirov contre garry
kasparov un match maintenant qui est
vraiment à la pointe de l'actualité
puisque alexei shirov gagnent tout et
kasparov aussi donc c'est vraiment deux
joueurs on attend qu'ils se rencontrent
mais le match n'aura pas lieu la guerre
de troie n'aura pas lieu puisque pour
l'instant l'adversaire choisi par garry
kasparov personnellement puisque gary
choisi ses adversaires c'est la dîmière
kramnik donc le match n'aura pas lieu
donc là je pense qu'on a fini pour cette
pour cette très belle partie parce
qu'ils cherchent une fois j'ai bon on va
passer à notre dernière rubrique
l'actualité de la semaine qui est très
riche qui est très chaud l'actualité de
la semaine
alors l'actualité de la semaine
elle est effectivement très très riche
d'abord donc là la fin du tournoi de
jaffa classique alors un tournoi de
catégorie celle je crois oui oui avec là
aussi des stars
polgar judith ouais c'est vrai qu'il
faut dire toujours les prénoms chez les
soeurs paul-guerre puisqu'elles sont
trois championnes radeef man donc le
champion du monde de la fidh et karpov
l'ex multiples champions du monde
pas besoin d'avoir mis l'eau ce qui est
un grand maître brésilien quand même
extrêmement forts qui s'est qualifiée
plusieurs fois pour le championnat du
monde et qui travaille avec un teint
jeunes actuellement leitao
donc ça joue bien on choisit les miloche
à un très bon représentant du déchet
brésilien sert à one servane le fameux
grand maître américain ian timan c'est
quand même une star en hollande
le patron d'un d'un journal qu'on vous
recommande winch est ce assez lente
excellente revue qui est très très
technique très analytique avec des
articles des papiers d'autres bonne
qualité à diallo a bientôt le joueur
philippin si je ne trompe pas voilà l
veste elle reste une valeur sûre des
échecs les tons des éléments et 2 2
joueurs que moi personnellement je ne
connais même pas peut-être que tu
collègues il a one oui oui mais les one
fait partie de ces nouveaux joueurs à
2600 qui ont qui démontre un peu les
problèmes du classement et nous enfin je
ne sais pas mort d'autres
une chose est sûre c'est que ce monsieur
good as one ne joue pas au placement qui
la voient là et le dernier the wind mais
à peu près là on n'a rien contre ces
gens là mais effectivement ils ont quand
même alors levé rapidement le classement
judit polgar qui revient avec 6 ennemis
sur neuf partis c'est ça oui ça c'est
une trêve c'est quand même un bon
résultat parce que judith a eu quand
même une phase difficile
je dis très clairement au creux de la
vague
elle avait des résultats moins bons
maintenant c'est beaucoup mieux judith
est en pleine forme je voudrais bien
enfin ici elle termine brillamment
première tout seul du tournoi alors ce
qu'il faut on rappeler quand même c'est
que la dernière ronde était fabuleuse
tout simplement puisque avec quatre
joueurs ex-aequo en tête il y avait à
l'ifan karpov donc championnes l'ex
champion du monde fis des et le nouveau
judit polgar la meilleure joueuse
féminine est l'élément surprise du
tournoi le grand maître brésilien
miloche et ces quatre joueurs par la
magie de l'appareil ont joué ensemble à
la dernière ronde
karpov contre carl hischmann alors un
nul c'est à dire que talisman avec les
blancs a dominé karpov
il l'a dominé dans tous les sens il a
interrompu son final et n'arrive pas à
conclure
chose incroyable quand on connaît la
technique du champion du monde actuel de
la fidh et donc alexander frei fans il
n'a pas réussi à conclure cette finale
qui était sans doute gagnante par des
dizaines de façons différentes
karpov s'est extrêmement bien défendu
nul et judit polgar avait des noirs donc
a priori contre un grand maître c'est
difficile de gagner si cette personne
est d'accord pour faire nul mais en tout
cas elle a été chercher mais vraiment
elle a été le chercher de très très loin
puisqu'elle a le fond de court elle a
fini avec un seul pion donc instruction
il y avait juste un pion qui a fait la
différence à la fin
elle a fait des menaces à l'exception
une diversion et elle a gagné une partie
dont contre miloche les gagner cette
ultime partie
elle s'est donc entre propulsé tout seul
en tête du classement du [ __ ] un
classique en indonésie donc ça nous fait
plaisir parce que quand même j'ai dit
c'est quand même la seule joueuse qui
joue au niveau des meilleurs grands
maîtres elle avait des problèmes et moi
je les aime bien julie t puis je sais
que stéphane laborde a mis aussi sa
soeur puisqu'il avait invité à bordeaux
il ya de ça quelques années et je suis
sûr qu'elle va revenir dans le diagonal
tour
quant à carl hischmann finalement il
prouve que il est quand même très fort
on va pas reparler des poèmes de la
fille d epuis bon bakar pop c'est pas la
peine on sait que lui même si
j'ai plus aux échecs et c'est un super
space qui maintenant ouais ça qu'il faut
comme lui passer dessus attendu karpov
toujours restera toujours karpov
il est très fort il est moins efficace
qu'avant ils calculent - mais toujours
la compréhension des champions du monde
et est au rendez vous et donc pour
battre karpov
il faut quand même se lever tôt le matin
mais moi j'avais une anecdote de timan
au trophée map à il ya dix ans il y
avait un commentateur qui lui demandait
vous dites timan avait dit oui karpov a
pas une bonne mémoire
si mal mais avec un accent un petit peu
difficile avec des oui il oublie
beaucoup mais il comprend beaucoup
voilà voilà pour karpov c'était mon
anecdote du jour alors et
un autre grand tournoi on va aller un
peu aux états unis parce qu'on joue
beaucoup là bas on joue beaucoup alors
on joue pas de la finalement joue pas eu
ce qu'ils aiment les américains sont les
tournois open
les tournois où il ya beaucoup de
joueurs là on a parlé de tournoi fermé
sur des tournois invitation vous avez
peu de joueurs des champions et les
tournois open où finalement les
champions c'est ça qui est sympathique
se mélangent aux amateurs de toute force
dans ces tournois là ça commence on peut
commencer à jouer à 10 700 lots et vous
avez des joueurs 2007
alors est ce que tu as déjà joué toi ce
tournoi de new york le new york open
alors je ne suis jamais allé à 120 de
new york
en revanche j'ai des amis joueurs
français qui sont allés il paraît qu'à
une particularité étonnante à ce tournoi
c'est qu'on amène son propre chic et
alors que là les organisateurs ne
fournissent pas de matériel il donne
juste des appareils mans ils attendent
un résultat
donc c'était le premier arrivé s'assoie
à la table qui veut bien avec son
échiquier et sa pendule les joueurs
s'installent joue et transmettre les
résultats à la route et ont même dit
qu'alors donc qui paraît même qu'il ya
plusieurs tournois qui jouent
simultanément vous perdez une ronde vous
pouvez vous inscrire à notre tournoi
plusieurs systèmes un poil alors c'est
extrêmement compliqué c'est vraiment à
l'américaine c'est à dire qu'on a sa
chance jusqu'au bout
tout le monde a sa chance et c'est
l'objectif de ce tournoi c'est
exactement ça c'est très américain
donc il ya des poules on peut changer de
poule ne pas venir une partie
on peut faire des nuls sans jouer
j'entends bien sans adversaire c'est à
dire dire non demain je ne joue pas je
fais nul donc il ya tout un tas de tout
un tas de choses mais enfin quand même
dans le tournoi principal c'est du
sérieux il ya soixante et un grand
maître qui viennent tous très très fort
l'année dernière ces trois arméniens qui
a gagné le tournoi c'était le trio
arménien avec minassian elle pétille ont
et anastasia ont donc trois très bons
joueurs arméniens qui avait trusté les
trois premières places
et cette année c'est pas tout à fait
pareil cette année c'est je vais donner
rapidement ses premiers elias mirin un
grand maître israélien très très fort un
très très fort deuxième igor ken keen
qu'on connaît bien puisqu'il vient
souvent en france il vit en allemagne
lui aussi très fort un troisième c'est
un américain nick des firmes yann voyez
un véritable américain exceptionnel
alexander goldin je crois que c'est
aussi un quelqu'un qu'on connaît bien
c'est un ami qui il a beaucoup joué en
france bon il est extrêmement fort
évidemment tout ça c'est des grands
maîtres donc d'origine russe n'aura par
deux firmes ion qui lui est américain il
ya beaucoup de russes qui se déplace à
new york en tout cas et ils trustent
c'est vers les premières places et on
peut vous dire après il ya très gros
beauf que des joueurs de 1600 christiane
scène qui viennent ça tu es un très bon
là un très bon livre storming des
barricades avec le mauvais accent qui me
caractérise adverys great chioukh donc
sachez quand même que vous avez des
joueurs comme paul hogan qui sont 18e et
vous avez des grands maîtres à la 60e
place voit la manière dont on n'est plus
ce qu'elle 61 ans m forcément il y en a
qui vont très loin
à noter la bonne performance de nos
joueurs français notamment christian
bauer qui termine 13e c'est quand même
pas pas facile du tout dans un tournoi
de ce niveau là donc christian bauer en
grande forme actuellement il a gagné le
tournoi de metz ex-aequo avec elkin
qu'un grand maître russe ici il termine
troisième en battant et pishin même à la
dernière ronde et chine meilleurs lots
du tournoi 2010 157 donc je sais on n'a
pas vu la partie n'est pas encore
disponible ça va nous permettre de
switcher aux championnats de france par
équipes où il a très bien joué aussi
bauer rien on va parler du championnat
france par équipes où ils avaient fait
nul contre galles fort et quand même
un super un super g amis oui tout à fait
dont christian bauer joue très très bien
en équipe il est très fort il a fait une
perf à plus de 2600 donc c'est un très
bon de remettre si actuellement d un des
meilleurs joueurs français on peut le
dire mais on peu peur de le dire
donc le champion de france par équipe
également une très belle poupée alors le
championnat de france par équipe j'y
participe moi je suis certainement le
p'tit quinquin
alors là aussi c'est sympathique parce
que vous avez des des joueurs comme toi
et comme toi et loi il ya les meilleurs
joueurs du monde comme gulf ans qui
viennent y acquérir gueorguiev quand
même des gens qui jouent à 2007 où 2650
et plus joël michael liles michael adams
bacrot enfin il ya vraiment sur les
premiers échiquiers donc ça se joue sur
faut redire sur neuf échiquier 8
échiquier plus un échiquier féminin
c'était une décision de la ffe diatta
quelques années pour promouvoir les
échecs féminin en france visiblement ça
a porté ses fruits
alors on va parler que des trois
premiers vous avez comme des équipes
professionnelles comme la tienne
1 la première c'est clichy un premier
c'est clichy sont souvent champion de
france
je vais commenter c'est mon championnat
clichy c'est ça fait des années qu'ils
ont
quelqu'un comme jean claude -1 qu'on
connaît bien maintenant sur diagonale tv
qui travaille beaucoup qui fait un
travail de fond qui fait un travail
aussi avec l'élite
parce que c'est important pour la ville
de clichy sont champions de france ils
ont été champions d'europe je crois ou
presque champion d'europe et ça te
permet de faire parler de la ville
montpellier c'est la ville du président
de la fédération française d'échecs
jean-claude loubatière donc c'est aussi
une équipe très forte
et puis ton équipe monaco
alors là je vais te laisser parler pour
monaco oui le club de monaco donc une
assez belle équipe puisque michael adams
qui participent qui est numéro 7 mondial
irun piquette ou le fondeur sonne donc
des noms assez prestigieux avec
notamment le coup de coeur de l'équipe
je dirais marque santoro mans trois fois
champion de france et habitués d ein hod
donc
qui nous a posé quelques soucis cette
année puisque effectivement un joueur
qui est envahie note c'est très très
difficile dans une équipe parce que
c'est quand même du jeu par équipe c'est
à dire qu'il faut tenir compte des
résultats des partenaires et des
adversaires et avec lui on ne sait
jamais ce qui va se passer il n'y a
aucune sécurité tout peut arriver il
peut jouer les meilleurs coûts et gagner
ou alors tombé tombé directement faire
des gaffes où je vais très bien comme
très mal voilà il toujours très bien
comme très mal donc ça ça a été notre
notre souci mais une fois de plus c'est
à dire jeudi a une fois de plus puisque
l'année dernière c'était la même chose
l'équipe de monaco s'est fait totalement
explosé par l'équipe qui choisit alors
qu'on affiche à peu près au tableau des
compositions équivalente un bon ces deux
très belles équipes bien sûr avec 2500
de moyenne à peu près donc c'est
vraiment du beau jeu mais là score final
5 1
ce qui est vraiment excessif qu'on peut
dire c'est qu'évidemment c'est il ya
quand même effectivement le jeu d'échecs
est un jeu individuel mais il ya quand
même un esprit d'équipé et vous
certainement que l'équipe de clichy ça
fait des années qu'ils jouent ensemble
ils se connaissent il ya quand même un
problème une sorte de de karma
camaraderie vue tout à fait ça s'est
fait par donc j'ai joué trois ans
l'équipe d'autriche y effectivement donc
je sais très bien ce qui se passe c'est
qu'il ya le président enfin le capitaine
de l'équipe qui est jean-claude - qui a
un secret pour motiver les troupes
c'est à dire que je ne sais pas ce qui
se passe mais il ya une ambiance
tellement exceptionnel dans cette équipe
que là ils jouent pas à neuf joueurs
mais plutôt à un bloc le fameux bloc
équipe très cher à clichy et donc tout
le monde se surpasse simultanément et ça
donne des très grosses cordes et très
très grosse partie tout le monde est
appliquée il terme extrêmement peu nos
événements qui choix donc clichy
champion de france par équipes alors
maintenant on va finir quand même soit
quelque chose de très important parce
que c'est la nouveauté canal web
eloi avec stéphane vous allez allez un
tournoi très important ces deux tournois
de sarajevo pourquoi il est très
important parce qu'il ya kasparov et il
ya bacrot voilà une très très belle
affiche c'est un scoop c'est la première
fois que ses joueurs vont se rencontrer
donc ils vont se rencontrer c'est sûr
etienne bacrot notre petit français en
forme qui au classement intermédiaire de
la fidh et vient de passer plus que 2600
donc ça on le savait il est très très
fort garry kasparov selon lui on ne
présente plus et le dominateur absolue
des échecs moderne il à 2850 maintenant
donc il va y avoir un choc etienne
bacrot garry kasparov ça va être très
très chaud puisque etienne joue très
bien très solide et perd très peu de
parties actuellement mais évidemment il
y aura d'autres
d'autres choses qu'à prévoir il y aura
pour etienne c'est kasparov assez
important en 16 dans les échecs et puis
c'est aussi de son premier super tournoi
puisque ce sera un catégorie 18 ou 19
j'ai peint vous savez comment compte les
catégories de tournois sont en calculant
la moyenne et l'aude et des joueurs là
ici des cas kasparov des quais les
meilleurs joueurs du monde ça ça monte
très haut ça remonte à 2007
donc là je crois de mémoire kasparov
bacrot short un call 2690 ou de 1680 il
y aura alors topalov qui doit être aux
alentours de 2007 est morose et vite je
crois il y aura sokolov silvan sokolov
qui est toujours un joueur du alentours
de 1650 60
enfin je me souviens plus tous les jours
mais tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que ça va être très dur pour etienne et
puis effectivement dans ce genre de
tournoi fermé
ils ont envie de lui faire mal aux
jeunes ils ont envie de lui dire tu as
pas me tape à la force est encore assez
fort non mais là et etienne va
clairement être le client du tournoi
clients guillemets puisque ils ont tous
une grosse expérience de c2c fort
tournoi donc ils vont tout cherché à
marquer le point facile
c'est à dire ils vont chercher ils ont
regardé la liste du tournoi bon alors là
y'a kasparov lui ça va être dur yachir
off ça va être dur aussi bien sûr qu'il
sera là bas il ya shirov également qu'il
sera là bas là je vais jouer
morose et beach numéro quatre mondial ça
va être très très dur donc là par contre
là il ya d'accrocs lui ça va lui il va
falloir que je le soigne je fais bien
mon occupé et je vais essayer de marquer
un point ici puisque les autres sont
très très fort donc tout le monde va
l'attendre
tout le monde va chercher à le battre ça
va être dur pour etienne mais maintenant
etienne est très fort également alors
vous vous pourrez aussi voir tout ça
parce que on a réussi encore une fois
canal web
on est allé voir jacques rosselin on l'a
dit il faut faire un spécial bacrot tous
les jours dans tous les matins le
lendemain matin de la ronde
vous aurez la partie de bacrot de
kasparov peut-être la partie du jour
exceptionnellement s'il ya une partie
exceptionnelle on dit j'irai en léger
différé par rapport au tournoi de
sarajevo et avec stéphane vous allez
partir deux ou trois jours là-bas pour
recueillir les impressions des joueurs à
la fin du tournoi
voilà donc ça va être une couverture
spéciale sarajevo sur des donald tous
les matins à partir de la première ronde
à 9h30 vous aurez votre flash sarajevo
avec le compte rendu
les positions et les classements la
partie intéressante du jour
les anecdotes sur qu'est ce qui se passe
là bas qui fait quoi et pourquoi et
comment donc tout sur sarajevo tous les
matins en une demi heure 9h30 10h et
pour finir avec le diagonal spéciale qui
sera je pense le 29 mai si je me trompe
pas vendredi 29 mai diagonale spéciale
avec le compte rendu et peut-être même
le reportage s'il est déjà fait alors on
leur donne les dates c'est important
pour vous chers télénautes c'est à
partir du 17 mai donc le lendemain matin
18 mai un première partie jusqu'au 29
et tous les matins à 9h30 évidemment
vous l'aurez en différé ça va tu es bon
qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter à etienne
et bien un bon tournoi bon on va
chercher les autres merci de nous avoir
suivis scheer et loire merci
nous avoir éclairé pour par tes
commentaires et puis je vous dis à la
semaine prochaine au revoir
oh